hey everybody
my name is stuart reischling from google
cloud i'm a product manager working on
traffic director
with me is kelsey hightower he's going
to be doing a demo later
today we're here to talk about building
an enterprise grade service mesh with
traffic director
so i'm going to go through a little bit
of pretext and prelude for why
a product like traffic director even
exists and why you should consider it
then we're going to talk about what
traffic director is we're going to go
into an awesome demo
that's going to give you a good sense of
you know how do you interact with this
product
how does it actually work i'll talk
through some of the problems that
customers are solving with traffic
director and then we'll go into some of
the announcements that we're going to
make today
so what is traffic director to
understand traffic director i think it
it helps to kind of think through a very
simple model so
i talk to customers all the time who are
dealing with problems like a retailer
who wants to try and make their
deployment production ready and so as a
retailer you might be doing very
you know retail things you have a
shopping cart service
you have a payment service the shopping
cart service uh helps your
customers add items to their carts and
then the payment service allows your
customers to pay for the stuff that they
want to buy
really straightforward stuff right the
types of things that you might want to
solve
as a retailer let's look at what that
looks like once you start trying to make
it production ready
and so here i have some code it's not
great
it's the type of code i might write it's
a checkout function
a charge customer function and then a
function that calls on both of those
you know very straightforward the types
of things that you might want to do as a
retailer
and you'll notice here that there's this
line of code
that is the payment endpoint this is the
end point that the shopping cart uses
when it wants to call the payment
service
and it's pretty straightforward you know
customers aren't really doing this stuff
anymore but kind of bear with me it's an
ip address
that the shopping cart's going to call
on
you'll notice that this simple model
you've got some business logic
you've got some non-business logic which
is that shopping cart
the payments endpoint pretty
straightforward and some more business
logic
you know not too bad you're just calling
this thing from your shopping cart
and now you get to a production you know
scenario where you need to make this
thing something that works for the
holiday season
and during the holiday season you might
have a lot of customers and you can't
really afford to have your
payments back end be overloaded and so
what do you do you need more capacity
well one way you get more capacity is
you create another payments backend
and your shopping cart now needs to be
able to call both of those back in so if
one of them is overloaded well that's
okay you've got another one
you know you can't afford to have your
payments failing because that's you know
money left on the table
and so you have two instances of your
payments back in your shopping cart
needs to kind of figure out
how to send traffic between them
we'll go back to our code and here is
the exact same snippet i showed before
i hit some of the checkout stuff because
you're going to see this starts to
become pretty clunky pretty fast
so rather than calling the one payments
endpoint
we need to be able to call two payments
endpoints in fact we need to be able to
load balance
between them and so one way that you
might do this is you might write a
load balanced endpoints function and so
rather than calling just
that one endpoint 1005 you now have this
1006
as well and you randomly choose between
one of them this is you know
pretty straightforward not too
complicated way of implementing
round robin load balancing occasionally
you'll send traffic to one endpoint
on other occasions you'll send traffic
to the other one and so this gives you a
pretty straightforward way to just load
balance between both
those payments back-ends but one of the
things that you'll notice here is that
whereas before i only have that one end
point now i have two end points i've
also had to think about how i choose
between those endpoints how i load
balance between those endpoints
and you know take a second to pause and
put yourself in the shoes of a retailer
what does this stuff have to do with
selling goods and services and products
to your customers
well not very much but you're now
responsible also for figuring this code
out and owning and maintaining this code
pretty straightforward we just figured
out how we could add another payments
backend and load balance between them
but you'll also notice that if you look
at your shopping cart code you're now
spending more of your time on this
non-business logic
and what i mean by non-business logic
here is basically
code that doesn't have very much to do
with you delivering your business at all
it has to do with things like resiliency
and up time
and dealing with you know big problems
that you might face that are more
infrastructure level than actually
delivering goods to your end customer
so okay you just got a little bit more
capacity for your holiday season well
now we have
a new requirement and that's you know we
can't just randomly choose an endpoint
we want to make sure that the shopping
cart only calls on payments backends
that are healthy
and so rather than just randomly
choosing one
which is what we did here is we are
going to actually test those endpoints
make sure that they actually are healthy
before we send traffic to them
and so rather than get load balanced
endpoint we update that function to be
get healthy load balanced endpoint and
you'll notice there's even a function
here
is healthy which i don't know how to
write this basically what this would do
is figure out
it's got that ip address 10.0.0.5
is it actually healthy it would go and
check
you know get healthy endpoints with look
at for each of the end points whether
they are healthy or not
and suddenly that chunk of code that
you're owning goes grows more and more
towards
infrastructure level problems networking
problems
and that's where you're dedicating more
and more of your time
and so again like we saw before your
code that is non-business logic
continues to grow
and again i need to ask you what does
that have to do with selling goods and
services to your customers
well not very much and the examples i
just showed you
are pretty straightforward you know ones
that a lot of customers might face well
i talk to customers who ask for all
kinds of things that i would put in the
non-business logic category
my customers have requirements like i
have payments back-ends or other
backends in multiple regions and
clusters
i need to be able to gracefully handle
timeouts
you know i might be handling private
information it needs to be encrypted
tracing and logging code needs to be in
there too
dynamically scaling up different
payments back-ends i might even have
development teams that want to operate
in multiple different languages
and so all of these things i would posit
are you know non-business logic and your
engineering efforts
go to more and more handling
infrastructure concerns
which takes away focus and resources
from delivering your payments
from delivering your shopping cart from
delivering your actual business
and so the good news is you know the
example i just showed you is a little
bit contrived
we've already found ways to solve this
customers have for a long time been
doing things like
running a load balancer in between the
shopping cart and the payment service
and so here that load balancer is
basically a proxy
the shopping cart sends traffic to it
the load balancer figures out where that
traffic should go
all of your non-business logic lives in
that load balancer
but even this pattern has its flaws
which is
you know that load balancer sits in
between but you might have more and more
client instances sending traffic through
it
and that starts to become a bottleneck
you now have to figure out you know how
do i scale this thing up
how do i make sure it doesn't go down
because it's a single point of failure
and you even see other patterns emerge
that i would also
characterize as smells you know you
might have for example a support service
which
supports important don't get me wrong
but at the end of the day your customers
are paying for goods and services
you know they're not paying for support
and so that's maybe a little bit less
critical
but i see plenty of customers who are
sending traffic from both
shopping cart critical services and
support front ends
less critical services through the same
proxy and
again you've got those issues around
scaling
making sure it doesn't go down but then
also you have this configuration that
now lives in your proxy belonging to
multiple different types of services
you need to make sure that if you make a
change to the support front end proxy
code it doesn't
cause an issue for your other services
and so now you're dealing with isolation
problems
and again all of these things go back to
the idea that you aren't really
delivering value to your customers
when you're working through these types
of problems
over the past couple of years we've seen
a pattern that helps us to solve this
and the idea here is you have a
dedicated client side load balancer
often that is a sidecar proxy and so
that might run right next to your
shopping cart on the left hand side you
see an individual
instance of that shopping cart it has
its own sidecar proxy that only has
logic for the shopping cart routing for
load balancing for the shopping cart
and you know if you want to scale up and
you have another shopping cart instance
well that has its own sidecar proxy and
so both of those can
independently load balance between your
payments back ends
if one shopping cart instance or one
shopping cart instances
sidecar proxy misbehaves the other one
is unaffected
and so this gives you a really nice
simple way to have client-side load
balancing
you get rid of those concerns around
bottlenecks of things that sit in the
middle
you've got configuration that's highly
tailored just to that shopping cart it's
not shared across multiple services
that's what the sidecar proxy model that
we've seen in the last couple of years
can do for you
and so far so good you know you
basically solved a lot of the problems
that i described earlier
but now you're getting yourself into a
new game and that is that you need to
figure out how you're going to configure
that sidecar proxy
so one way you might do that and i just
made this up this is a proxy.com file
imagine you know a json file or a yaml
file
it contains you know the configuration
for your sidecar
it has the endpoints for the payments
backends
it has maybe how you're going to do
health checks for those
you know it's got the information that
the proxy needs in order to support that
shopping cart
and so okay fine writing a proxy.com for
one sidecar proxy
no big deal right and so what happens
when you have a new payments backend
well you're configuring your proxies
again and so a way to do that
is you write yourself another proxy.conf
and i think you can already see where
i'm going with this but
you've now effectively started to take
on this additional responsibility which
is
how do i write distribute store
proxy configuration and in this case you
know this is still pretty trivial
when i talk to customers who are doing
you know really enterprise
enterprise-grade stuff
um they have deployments that look far
more complicated they have deployments
that look more like this
you know multiple regions multiple
services some even hundreds or thousands
of services
each running their own sidecar proxies
or middle proxies
you know with things like encryption
turned on
or different load balancing policies and
so now
you've got yourself into the game of
writing and configuring proxy.conf
files and if you talk about expanding
the number of services expanding the
number of regions
this all just becomes way more
complicated you see customers doing
things like
checking these in have validation in
place for proxy.com
files figuring out how to make sure that
you know there's no
issues in those proxy.com files and i'll
go back to the thing at the very
beginning which is
if you are a retailer what does that
have to do with selling goods and
services to your customers
and again you know people have solved
this there's a solution for it
it's called a control plane and so the
control plane is a service
that is basically responsible for
writing distributing making sure
proxy.com
gets to the right sidecar proxies it
might have an api
it might have you know different checks
to make sure the sidecar proxies are
helpful
and you've probably seen things like
this for example istio is a great
example istio has a component called
pilot and all that really is is a
control plane
that runs in your cluster you have some
apis to tell it hey this is what the
world should look like
these are the policies that i want to
enforce and then
pilot will take that and go and
distribute it to all of your sidecar
proxies
and so you know i talk about pilot as an
example of a control plane
another example of a control plane is
traffic director
traffic director is a control plane as a
service
it's a gcp managed service i'll talk a
little bit more about what traffic
direct what makes traffic director
special
but at its core it's a control plan you
don't have to install it update it any
of that stuff
it runs within gcp it knows about the
world because you tell it what the world
should look like and it also collects
signals really intelligently from your
infrastructure and it generates that
configuration for your proxies
and so what is traffic director well
there's four things that i want you to
keep
in mind traffic director is a universal
managed control plane
and so what do i mean when i mean
universal i mean one part of that is
that it's
global by default you know it looks at
your whole network as
a global thing and so that includes not
just
containers but also virtual machines you
know plenty of customers
aren't ready to go you know 100 into
kubernetes yet and that's totally okay
whether you're on vms on containers
traffic director really doesn't make a
distinction about which services it's
supporting
if you know it's got for example an
envoy proxy on the virtual machine or on
the container
that connects to traffic director using
a set of apis that known as the xds apis
traffic director will send it
configuration back
the other thing that's really cool about
traffic director is it's not just
gcp we're starting to now have
and you'll see more about this later you
know customers have deployments in
gcp and non-gcp environments and other
clouds and so for us being able to
support those other environments
is really key you'll see in a second
about
what that means practically in terms of
what we're delivering but just think of
traffic director as
global as something bigger than just gcp
as something that's bigger than just
vms so if i can reinforce that further
it's the fact that
traffic director is more than just a
service mesh you know service mesh is a
type of
deployment that traffic director can
support
it works really well with service mesh
but we're also starting to see
customers working with more than just
these sidecar proxies deployed in
service mesh we're starting to see
customers who are using application
libraries
without proxies and we'll talk about
what that means in a second as well
and also we're seeing customers who are
just deploying you know an envoy proxy
on a virtual machine that acts
as a load balancer you know similar to
that model i showed earlier
the one before the sidecar based model
where you don't necessarily
have to be ready to add sidecar proxies
everywhere to get value from traffic
director
our goal is to support a lot more than
just the traditional model where you
have
sidecar proxies next to your application
workloads we want to follow you where
your deployment is and what your
topology looks like is something that we
want to support
the third thing to keep in mind is
that's programmable so
we've got an api that used to configure
traffic director
we've got a rich set of policies so
traffic management policies layer 7
based
policies we've got a lot of other
interesting policies coming up as well
but this gives you a centralized way to
manage all of your configuration your
policies in a single place
you don't need to worry about
distributing policies about
sort of hand crafting them it's a
programmable interface that you can use
to configure your application network
and then finally and this is what really
distinguishes it from a lot of other
solutions is it's a control plane as a
service
what i mean here is that it's a managed
service managed by gcp
it's got an sla our sres are kind of
making sure that it doesn't go down and
if there is an issue we're taking care
of that for you
it gets rid of a lot of the things that
i would call you know
not really related to your business
around how do i install a control plane
how do i keep it up how do i make sure
that
you know the state of my control plane
is replicated across multiple regions
these are all really fundamentally
difficult problems that
you if you're a retailer if you're a
bank if you're a pharmaceutical company
that's not really your business and
you're not really deriving much value
from taking on that responsibility
and so with that i'm going to pass it on
to kelsey who's going to make it
make it real he's going to show a demo
kelsey off to you
all right thank you stewart so we're
going to jump right into it as we just
talked about
traffic director is kind of center for
all of our service configuration
and the heart of our service mesh in gcp
it's
often paired with the thing called envoy
so sidecar
some people look at it as just a proxy
the nice thing about it is
envoy supports the standard xds protocol
for its configuration
that means i can point in that traffic
director to grab all this configuration
a lot of you will be familiar with the
similar process that you see in
something like istio
but what happens if the overhead of
having an additional sidecar like envoy
becomes too high maybe for a high
performance scenario or what about the
management overhead of having to manage
another binary
and its configuration and the
interesting thing that we're going to
talk about today
is proxy list service mesh if you think
about it
there's lots of high performance
frameworks out there grpc is one of my
favorites
inside of grpc we now have native xds
integration so what does that mean well
it means that we can actually get our
configuration
from traffic director just like envoy
and once we have our configuration we
can actually have back-ends
and we can do some of the traffic
management features that you normally
find
in a broader service mesh or a proxy
like envoy
now to set this up we need some services
now i can run my services on vms but
kubernetes is one of my favorite
platforms
so what we're looking at here is just a
basic kubernetes cluster called next
if i were to drill into this kubernetes
cluster i have
a deployment of my calculator app and
i'll show you how that calculator apps
works in the moment
just know i have a set of containers
deployed to kubernetes
now i have three of these and they're
set up with the auto scaler to go up to
up to 10 if i need it
now typically when you have multiple
instances of something you'll typically
have a low balancer so let's click into
that
so here's my service configuration
you'll notice
this is just a standard kubernetes
service object
there is no load balancer at all all i
have is a collection of pods
and their ip addresses so we're going to
need something else to handle
the load balancing aspects for us now
the nice thing about this is
the proxy list grpc integration we can
actually do this
on the client side by getting the
configuration from traffic director
so before we do that we need to make
sure we understand
how the calculator app actually works so
the thing you have to keep in mind is
we're not going to change the way we
write code here
for example i can write a standard grpc
application and test it on my laptop so
let's do that now
i'm just going to cd into this
calculator directory this is where the
source code lives
and here's the server instance i'll just
go ahead and build that really quickly
so we can actually take a detailed look
at how it actually works now the server
calculator app all it does is expose an
endpoint where i can call
an add method and give it an array of
numbers and have it give us back a
result
once that's done compiling we'll run it
right here from my laptop
so here we go we'll run that here so you
can see that it's starting
listening on port 5051 commonly the
default grpc port
and i also have my health checks on port
8080 so that's running locally here
the next thing we'll do is we'll take a
look at the client now the client side
code is pretty straightforward
lcd into that directory and then what
we'll do here is i'm just going to
compile the client
and this is going to be a very standard
kind of request and response grpc
application
so as we're building our client once
it's set up we'll take a look at its
command line flags to see what options
we have
all right so now that the client is
built let's take a look at those flags
and we'll see that we can give it a
calculator flag and we can tell it where
the calculator service is running
so by default it's going to look on
service host
on port 551 and then we can give it a
list of things to calculate
pretty straightforward so let's just run
that now so we'll say client
and then we'll give it a couple of
numbers we'll say 10
20 and you don't have to be great at
math to get the answer for this
and we can see that the result is 30
right pretty straightforward
now what if we want to send our
application
the server somewhere else well remember
i packaged up that server component
into this calculator app that's running
inside of gke
or kubernetes and you'll see here that
we have multiple instances running
ideally you want an ha service and then
we also have it configured
to listen onto this port 551
now what if i wanted to actually do this
from a virtual machine and no longer my
laptop
now we have to deal with the
complexities of service discovery and
making sure that we can load bounce
across
all those back-ends so the first step we
got to do before we can do anything else
we need to configure traffic director
so i'm going to pop over to traffic
director now what you'll see here is
that
i have one service healthy but if i
scroll down here
you'll actually see something
interesting you'll see that i have one
network
endpoint group when i created my service
inside of kubernetes
i told the gke cluster to actually
manage a network endpoint group
that has all those pods behind it so if
we have three or ten
all of them will be grouped behind this
network endpoint group
you also see this green check box here
what this is saying
is that traffic director is doing its
own set of health checks to make sure
that all of those pods are actually
healthy before we send the configuration
with those backends in it
to any client-side grpc application
looking to leverage these
the last thing we need here is also how
do we communicate
what service do we want and this is
where some of the routing rules come
into play
now if you have any experience with
google cloud load balancer products
this is going to look very familiar to
you first we're going to start with the
grpc protocol
we're going to associate a set of
services that we created early on the
services tab
and if you click on calculator here what
we'll see
is that we give it a couple of name
matches
so here calculator plus that port
combination will route us
to this grp service called calculator
right so now all the configuration is
set on the server side
now the next thing we have to do on the
client side is we need to tell
grpc how to do this now you're probably
thinking
do i have to rewrite my entire
application to make this work
well the good news is with one import
statement we can make this work
automatically
i'm just going to pop over to github
really quickly so we can actually see
what the code looks like
so here we're going to click on our main
code i'm just going to zoom in a little
bit here so we can see what's going on
this is the only import that we have to
do
and if you look at this it's not going
to we're not going to actually use xds
anywhere we're just going to load
the client-side load balancing and
service discovery components that make
it compatible with traffic director
so this is an xds compliant server side
client-side load balancing
so with that in place we've got one more
step that we need we actually have to
tell
that bit of code where traffic director
is
so here we have a service uri so this is
going to be our xds control plane in
this case traffic director
we're going to use our service account
credentials so we can authenticate to it
and when we register with traffic
director we have to pass a little bit
information about ourselves
mainly our project number and what
network we care about
now one thing to keep in mind here is my
kubernetes cluster is running in a
network in my vpc called google
kubernetes engine and that's super
important
and we have to let traffic director know
that's the network that we would like to
find services in
and the last thing is traffic director
is really intelligent
about routing our traffic to let's say
the nearest zone
so if i'm in us1a and i have multiple
kubernetes clusters with the same
application deployed
it will be nice to have traffic director
user locality information
to give me an optimized set of back-ends
maybe for things like latency or for
zone is down
redirected me to another zone that's
available
all right so now that we have all our
configuration let's copy
this client binary to a vm
so we're going to do here is i'm just
going to copy the pre-built binary
to one of our vms that i have in my
infrastructure
so we'll just take a look at that
calculator binary make sure that we have
it for the client you see it here
and what i'm going to do really quickly
is i'm just going to scp
this binary to a little vm i call proxy
list grpc so let's just run that command
really quickly
so we're going to do here is just going
to copy this binary that i just ran on
my laptop
unmodified code to that virtual machine
and now what we're going to do is ssh to
that virtual machine
and once we're on that virtual machine
we'll have the ability to run the same
code again
but this time we're going to try to hit
the containers running in kubernetes
so we need a couple of things first we
need to make sure that our environment
is set up correctly
we have to tell xds where our bootstrap
file is so you'll see this environment
variable
being set to my local file system where
the xds bootstrap
configuration file is so we'll just
source that to make sure that our
environment is ready
and this time we're going to do
something slightly different with our
client connection
so we're not dealing with localhost
anymore we're going to do something
slightly different
with our calculator flag we're going to
give it the xds schema
and what this will do is it will tell
the xds library and all our client
side load balancing to look up the
service
inside of traffic director that's going
to be just enough so it bypasses the
normal lookup service in my case dns by
default
let's give it a couple of numbers we
have 1 and 56 we'll run it now
and we see that we get the results of 57
just to make sure that this is a live
demo
let's just pick some random numbers here
one plus 999
it's 1 000. everything is working great
i know you might be thinking like this
is a virtual machine how hard would it
be to
install envoy in a virtual machine and
just use envoy to keep
everything standard and you'll make a
good point it doesn't necessarily
address the need for
high performance if you want to avoid
the proxy but you're right
on a virtual machine we do have the
ability to just run
envoy as a sidecar right there on the
virtual machine and bypass doing
any of this so this is another thing
that i wanted to try
now this might get me in trouble with
the pm team because this is not
something that we advertise is working
but what's a live demo without a little
bit of creativity
one environment that i like a lot and
really makes sense for a proxy list
integration with traffic director is
cloud run
if you're not familiar with cloud run
it's our serverless
offering where i can run my containers
so earlier we just showed running on a
laptop
running on a virtual machine but think
about cloud run
i don't have the option of running any
additional sidecars
i can only provide my application and
that's it
so in this particular environment is
pretty constrained in terms of what i
can do
so the nice thing about this is i have
the ability now to do the exact same
thing
that i was doing on that virtual machine
on a serverless offering
like cloud run you'll even notice here
that i'm passing in the command line
flag that matches the exact same one
that i was running earlier now we did
something a little bit different here i
took all of that client code that you
saw
earlier and i moved it into an http
handler so
if this is all working i should be able
to call curl
hit the cloud run url and then the
client code will basically
use this is the same address that we
were using before
call out to traffic director get all of
the back ends
that it needs to route traffic to now
there's one more gotcha here
cloud run runs in a slightly different
network than my vpc
so i had to set up one more thing before
i could run my application
i had to set up a vpc connector
now in the serverless world we can set
up these connectors to be very specific
to a specific
network in this case the google
kubernetes network that i have set up
earlier is where my kubernetes cluster
is running and all those containers
and it also matches the configuration
that traffic director has
all i'm doing here is setting up this
serverless connector
called calculator so when i deploy my
cloud run application
i can also give it that vpc connector
name
to ensure that when this container
starts up it'll also
be able to have a lag into that vpc and
the last thing
we can also replicate the fact that i
have this xds
bootstrap config inside of this
environment variable letting me know
where to resolve
just like in the vm and we'll take one
more peek at something else just to make
sure we're all clear on how this
actually works
if i go over here to the calculator i
want to show you the docker file that i
used to create that container
i want to show you that we don't
actually have to change our code too
much
there's a lot of noise here so i'm just
going to break it down i'm building the
calculator app just like i built earlier
on my laptop
the big difference that i'm doing here
is i'm taking the binary from this step
i'm also copying in this xds bootstrap
config
into the container image now the nice
thing about that is i have
all the things i need necessary to call
traffic director
and i run one deployment script and if
everything is working
i should be able to call that particular
endpoint
so i have my curl command this is the
url from cloud run
and what we'll do is we'll pass in a few
integers here to see if we can get this
calculation
you can see it coming up pretty fast
those are pretty big numbers and some of
you may be struggling with math so let's
make it a slightly easier
for the viewers so we'll give you one
three
and five and you see that our answer is
nine
and with that i would like to end this
presentation as you can see
traffic director is super flexible in
terms of implementing a standard xds
protocol
combine that with proxy list grpc
integration we can now take a
standard xds client run it on my laptop
a virtual machine or even a serverless
environment like cloudrun
and we don't have to manage any other
binaries to get
what feels like a native service mesh
integration
and with that back to you stuart
all right nice thank you very much
kelsey so
you know so far we've gone through uh
context on why something like traffic
director exists
what it is kelsey brought it to life by
showing you you know how someone might
interact with it what are some of the
really cool things you can do with it
another thing i wanted to get into is
just what our customers what i see
customers actually using this product
for because
it's good to understand it it's good to
see you know some hands-on but
what are real problems that customers
are solving when they use traffic
director
and i'm going to interweave in this some
of the new announcements that we have as
well
and so let's go back to the case of a
retailer and i know i keep harping on
these large global retailers but i think
they're a great example because
in retail you really can't afford any
down time
and so something like black friday
coming up where every single second
is money lost if you're down is exactly
where a product like traffic director
shines
and so what you see in front of you
right now is an example of the type of
deployment that you might see with
traffic director
so we've got traffic director running
separate from your
region separate from your deployment
it's a managed service that you don't
have to manage yourself
and here we've got an example deployment
we're in multiple regions you're in u.s
central one
you're in asia southeast one you've got
replicas of the same services so you
might have a retail front end
hosted in kubernetes engine in both us
central one
and in asia southeast one you have that
because
you know some of your customers maybe
are in the us other customers are in
asia southeast one
so you want to make sure that when they
send you a request
it goes to the nearest services so you
reduce your latency you reduce your
network
travel costs you also want to make sure
that you've got
replicated services in case one goes
down
and so what i'm going to show you is how
traffic director makes it super easy to
just
automatically fail over so you've got
your retail front end
your shopping cart your payments each of
these are hosted in multiple regions so
that you can meet those goals around
latency around cost around high
availability
and so customers are using traffic
director in combination with
other gcp products as well what you see
here on the left hand side is the global
load balancer so this might be
you know a global https load balancer
and what that does is it gives you an ip
address that
your clients on the public internet can
send traffic to
and so that might look something like
this your client sends
traffic to your global load balancer and
let's say your client happens to be in
u.s central one while the global load
balancer is smart enough to send that
traffic to u.s central one
that minimizes latency that minimizes
cost
and so now your retail front end you
know which is what they're interacting
with
they add something to their shopping
cart and your retail front end needs to
be able to reach the shopping cart
that shopping cart might be on compute
engine and it might just happen that for
some reason in u.s central one well your
shopping cart is down
maybe you deployed a new version of your
service that didn't work
maybe you um you know you've got some
planned down time
and so what would happen here is rather
than having your retail front end
send traffic to the shopping cart and
hit errors for that end user
that traffic just goes to your shopping
cart in asia southeast one it just
fails over seamlessly to another region
and this is actually pretty
straightforward to set up a traffic
directory you just
add back ends in multiple regions as
part of your service
and traffic director will make sure that
your retail front end knows how to reach
the ones that are healthy
and so the shopping cart can go to your
payment service all's good
your customer gets served despite the
fact that your shopping cart in u.s
central one happened to be down
that automatic failover for highly
availability
super critical in the type of business
where you
have to make sure that every uh request
is handled
in a high quality way and gives a good
end user experience because
if that doesn't happen that's money left
on the table for you as a business
another use case i see i've got a
customer who's one of the world's
leading logistics providers
is that they have to make sure that when
they deploy a new version of the service
they don't have any downtime
and so just for a little bit of context
here this customer has a prediction
service
running and what that service does is
it tries to figure out when a package is
going to be delivered
well they do that by training a machine
learning model and deploying that
model as part of a workload that's
running on kubernetes engine
they need to retrain that model every
once in a while and redeploy that
and so what that means is when they do
that deployment they need to make sure
that that model
actually works and that the deployment
happens successfully
anyone who's done deployments knows that
a deployment is inherently risky
you might try to make sure that you have
a development environment a staging
environment a production environment
sort of qualify that new version as it
goes through
but no two environments are identical
and so
even if you do everything in staging and
validate that it works in staging
there's still some risk that once you
get to production
it's going to go down and so this is a
great example of how we see
customers using traffic director in this
example the front end is sending traffic
to the prediction service there's a
prediction v1 which is the old version
prediction v2 which is the new version
of the model
the the customer has set a traffic split
policy
which causes the front end to send a
percentage of traffic to the old one a
percentage of traffic to the new one
and as you validate that the model is
good you can continue to increase that
percentage of traffic
and so suddenly your deployments are a
lot safer because you only subjected a
small percentage of your traffic to the
new version
you've checked that it worked if it
didn't actually work well you can flip
that back to 100 to the old version
this gives you a lot of safety around
your deployments
it also unlocks all kinds of really
interesting devops patterns like
blue green deployments canary
deployments you know these are the types
of things that organizations are doing
these days and you can use
traffic director to deliver those types
of use cases
another really interesting one is this
idea of network edge services for gcp
and also this is new for non-gcp
environments and i'll talk a little bit
more about what i mean
by network edge services in both gcp and
non-gcp environments so
i've got plenty of customers you know
large banks for example who
have services that run in gcp and they
also have services that run
in their own on-prem data center and
that might be you know a temporary state
as they're migrating everything to the
cloud but it also might be a permanent
state there are all kinds of really
valid and good reasons why
you might want to have some workloads in
the cloud and some workloads in on-prem
and this is great right makes a lot of
sense
one of the things that customers come to
gcp for is
you know our global load balancer and
this is similar this is the same as what
i mentioned earlier
and this global load balancer is the
thing that delivers to you this
group of services that i call network
edge services
and so what do i mean by that i mean
that when a client sends traffic to the
global load balancer
there's all kinds of different policies
and services that you can apply there
an example is cloud armor you want to
make sure that you have ddos protection
in place so that your
clients on the public internet aren't
overloading your back ends
and so this checks to make sure that you
know the traffic that's coming in is
safe
you might have cloud cdn for content
distribution so
this helps you deliver results more
quickly to your end users it also saves
you a bunch of cost by caching different
static assets
that are delivered by the load balancer
the load balancer also has all kinds of
really interesting features
built into it things like a global
anycast vip so that you get a single ip
address that you can use
around the world and your clients can
just address
that ip address it'll go to the closest
instance and that's how you minimize
that latency
minimize that cost and i mentioned these
things because
you know customers look at this and they
go great i can use all of this with my
cloud service i can make sure that if i
have a cloud service
it's protected i'm caching things the
right way
but you know i as a you know bank for
example
don't really have that same global
footprint that gcp has
i don't have points of presence all
across the world where i can deliver
a global anycast vip where i can do you
know
different security mechanisms that are
you know
technically or for cost reasons
infeasible for me to deliver myself
well wouldn't it be great if you could
actually have that for your on-premises
services
as well and so one of the things that we
see as very critical for traffic
director is the ability to support more
than just gcp
um and so today what i'm showing you is
the ability to
actually use that those edge services
with your on-prem services and so what
does that look like well
that looks like a you know pool of
proxies deployed here on a compute
engine managed instance group
that managed instance group is just part
of our infrastructure it scales up and
down dynamically
each of those is running a proxy
and it acts as a middle proxy load
balancer it connects to traffic director
to get configuration
an example of the type of configuration
would be hey
there are these on-premises endpoints
each of them belonging to the on-prem
service that you see on the right-hand
side traffic director knows about that
because you've configured it that way
traffic director lets the proxy know
about it and so now the next time a
client
sends traffic to the global load
balancer that traffic can go to the
metal proxy
that proxies and forwards the traffic
onto your on-prem service
and so this is a really powerful use
case where you can get things like cloud
armor cloud cdn
global anycast you know these network
edge services for both gcp services
and services running in non-gcp
environments
we also see you know this this is a a
key investment for us which is this
infrastructure is really interesting but
you know how do you go from zero to
deployed well
we want to make that as easy as possible
and so what you see here is
the current way of deploying something
that you would call a service mesh
you have some compute engine services
these could be kubernetes as well
you've got maybe a front end and a back
end each of them has a sidecar proxy
and setting this up um you know it's not
that hard
but it does require some thought you
know where do i get this proxy
what's the version that i want to use
how do i make sure the version is secure
and i keep it up to date
um you know how do i you have to do
things like configure ip tables
um and if you're like me you know before
i started
even looking at traffic directory i had
never even messed with ip tables and i
talked to customers who were like this
thing is really scary because
if you misconfigure it well you can
suddenly drop a whole bunch of traffic
and you don't want to have to do that
and so a lot of customers find that
deploying sidecar proxies not the
easiest thing in the world so we want to
make that a lot easier for you
and so another thing that i'm showing
here today is a new way
of deploying uh your sidecar proxies and
you know a really easy way to think
about it is it's basically a virtual
machine template
it's a virtual machine template that you
control with some flags with some
parameters you know dash dash service
proxy enabled
and what that will do is it will
automatically onto your virtual machines
which could be running like a client
application or a server application too
onto those virtual machines the template
will install envoy a recent version that
we've qualified
it will connect it to traffic director
it will do things like set up ip tables
for you so you don't have to
deal with you know things that might be
very foreign to you which again have
very little to do with actually
delivering your services and it gives
you a really easy way to do
updates um you know it's as easy as do
is issuing a couple of commands to
initiate
a rolling update you don't need to think
about picking an envoy
compiling that envoy the envoy proxy
compiling it deploying it setting things
up
that's all handled for you um and so
another thing uh that we're announcing
um and kelsey showed this before is this
idea of using an application library
instead of an envoy proxy
we've got you know traffic director
support for proxis grpc services
and what do i mean by that um what i
mean by that is
if you look at the most recent versions
of grpc
they support this protocol called xds
xds is a group of apis that are used by
traffic director the control plane and
things like the envoy proxy or like grpc
to exchange information
about the world about the network about
your topology about what the endpoints
are that you want to reach
and so much the same way as when you
have envoy deployed
when you're using a recent version of
grpc
you can provide it some configuration
when you start it up
you use a different xds resolver it
connects to traffic director traffic
director tells that proxy
what are the different endpoints
associated with the services they're
trying to reach
because you'll you'll notice very
quickly if you've used grpc before it's
a super powerful application framework
but it doesn't come with everything that
you need to do a distributed service
um you see a lot of customers who are
doing things like adding an envoy proxy
so your
application goes to that onboard proxy
which then sends the traffic and that's
totally fine it's super feature rich it
works really well for a lot of customers
but if you're finding that you know
adding an envoy proxy is something that
you know maybe you can't do for reasons
like you know you can't
really add a sidecar you can't mess with
ip tables
those types of things well now you have
another way where if you're using grpc
you can very easily get the benefits of
service mesh
simply by updating to a new version
changing your x your resolver to the xds
resolver
and connecting it to traffic director
and this gives you already straight out
of the box
service discovery you know what are the
end points that i'm trying to reach
it gives you load balancing and we're
working on all kinds of other
interesting things that are super
relevant here
things like more traffic management and
so stay tuned for that you're going to
see that
the goal is that we bring all of the
capabilities that are relevant to grpc
that you can get in something like envoy
to grpc as well
so example benefits here are much easier
way to adopt service mesh
also performance we found that in some
cases this can be more performant than
if you have to go through
an envoy proxy first and obviously this
is going to depend on your use case what
you're doing exactly
but also a very interesting thing to
explore especially if you're already
thinking about grpc for
performance benefits this can get you
even further
um and so with that i want to wrap up
and say thank you very much for
listening today
if you've got questions there's a dory
where you can ask those questions we'll
be
looking at the questions trying to get
them answered for you if you're new to
traffic director check out the docs
there's a setup guide that walks you
through end to end how this stuff works
and also you know some of the things
that i showed you today may not be
released yet
at the time where this comes out so if
you have questions you know drop them in
the dory
um or i created this form that you can
use go to the form check it out
you can request access and we'll try to
get back to you as soon as possible
so with that i want to say you know
thank you very much for having me
big shout out to the traffic director
team who keeps pushing this product
forward
thanks kelsey for helping us with the
demo today and that's it for me
you